angela la audiencia sigue a porque
recordemos que las audiencias se
realizan sólo por la tarde así que va a
durar hasta tarde esta primera ya que
como habíamos avanzado antes este primer
día así como mañana y pasado mañana
están dedicado a pasar listas a los
acusados y también a las partes civiles
que como bien decías son más de 1800
efectivamente la audiencia se suspendió
porque uno de los acusados se sintió mal
y allí fue cuando sadam abdeslam salió
en su defensa diciendo que se siente mal
porque los tratan mal y que a él estos
últimos seis años lo han tratado como un
perro pero antes ya en la mañana tesla
me había causado polémica pues cuando
pasaron lista los acusados y le
preguntaron cuál era su trabajo él dijo
soy un combatiente del grupo estado
islámico dejé mi trabajo para ser un
combatiente del issys le preguntaron el
nombre de su madre y de su padre y él
dijo ellos no tienen nada que hacer aquí
no quiso decir sus nombres y eso
generado en general mucha reacción
recordemos que hay muchas víctimas que
están presentes le preguntamos
justamente al abogado de unos rescatados
del plata- clan que le parecía las
declaraciones de esa larga slam que
comenzó además sus declaraciones
diciendo que ala es el único dios es un
mensajero escuchemos lo que nos dijo
este abogado
me crió edite a mis clientes en realidad
esperan muy pocas cosas del proceso
esperan que les mantengan informados de
cómo se desarrollan los debates esperan
ciertas respuestas a algunas de sus
preguntas y yo les he preparado para el
hecho de que podrían no obtenerlas y
también esperan conocer más información
sobre el desarrollo de las
investigaciones y sobre las
responsabilidades es un punto que les
interesa particularmente
angela también pudimos conversar con el
abogado de uno de los acusados que
obviamente están en el ojo de la opinión
pública escuchemos lo que nos dijo
swain un médico de urgencias trata al
enfermo que le traen del hospital del
mismo modo yo acepto la defensa de quien
acude a mí para pedirme lo mientras no
vaya contra mi conciencia mi cliente
espera poder explicarse ante los jueces
de macintosh
va a hablar siempre respondió a todas
las preguntas que se le hicieron durante
la instrucción y continuará hablando y
respondiendo a todas las preguntas que
se le hagan
angela es solo el comienzo de un largo
juicio que como les hemos informado se
va a extender por nueve meses estaremos
aquí informándoles siempre por lo menos
mañana y pasado mañana también